focus people c'était très touchant ce
qui s'est passé c'est Lola Zidi donc ça
grand-mère si je dis pas de bêtises
c'était la femme de Claude Zidi oui
grand grand réalisateur qui a parlé
c'est la fille d'Yves Rénier qui révèle
l'existence de sa demi-sœur cachée donc
on va regarder un magnéto sur elle elle
a décidé d'en parler là maintenant
Irénée Moria 2 ans il y avait d'ailleurs
fait en réalisateur il était très bon et
puis c'était Commissaire Moulin j'adore
Yves Rénier pourquoi il a caché cette
fille comme ça toute sa vie qui était sa
demi-sœur et aujourd'hui en gros il lui
a demandé sur son lit de mort de de la
réintégrer dans leur vie de famille elle
en a fait un bouquin et elle vient en
parler c'est très beau et en même temps
on comprend pas pourquoi en fait il
régnait a caché cette fille regardez le
récap et on reçoit tout de suite sa
demi-sœur donc pardon le lasili
il nous a malheureusement quitté depuis
bientôt deux ans Yves Rénier était sans
aucun doute le plus célèbre des
commissaires français tout ce que je
vous demande c'est de répondre OUI ou
NON à mes questions d'accord pendant 30
ans l'acteur a campé avec brio le rôle
du commissaire Moulin sur TF1 mais c'est
en 1965 que le comédien a connu son
premier succès en incarnant le
personnage principal de la série
Belphégor et le fantôme du Louvre je
peux vous affirmer que Belphégor n'est
ni une apparition ni une fable oh me
multiples talent Yves régnait également
illustré derrière la caméra en tant que
réalisateur j'ai pas fait pour le fric à
son actif plusieurs succès le téléfilm
sur le drame Jacqueline sauvage qui a
rassemblé plus de 9 millions de
téléspectateurs sur TF1 mais aussi celui
sur le serial killer Michel fourniré
intitulé La Traque qui réalisera
également de bonnes audiences sur la
première chaîne moi j'essaye tout
simplement de raconter une histoire
lorsqu'il nous a quitté en 2021 cet
homme offrant par les légendaires qui
restera à tout jamais le premier flic de
France les gens ils pensent que mon
métier essaie cette flics n'avait
pourtant pas révélé tous ses secrets les
plus intimes dont l'existence de sa vie
cachée Christophe fille que l'acteur n'a
jamais reconnu
[Musique]
voilà on va essayer de comprendre et du
coup on rend hommage à Yves Rénier que
j'adorais mon Costa un gamin sur sa moto
c'était quoi
sa moto mais il en a eu plusieurs 1h je
sais qu'il a eu une aire je crois à une
époque il aimait bien la vitesse il
aimait bien les motos et après un moment
il s'est calmé je voulais juste dire un
mot pardon parce que on va pas
comprendre sinon il y a Natacha mal que
temps l'arme je crois que vous vous
connaissez
mais parce que j'étais 11 ans sur le
Commissaire Moulin j'étais 11 ans la
fiancée du Commissaire Moulin avec des
très longs cheveux tout ça peu importe
mais j'ai connu donc la fille aînée très
bien Samantha que j'adore des conseils
croisés dans les bras on est parti en
vacances avec avec la petite bouche là
on est parti aussi en vacances plusieurs
fois parce que je faisais de la famille
oui je connais aussi les deux petits
en fait à partir du moment où je suis
rentrée dans le fan de loi il y a
vous étiez pas vu depuis quand la
dernière fois que je t'ai croisé tu
jouais au théâtre de ma mère et ta maman
oui et donc est-ce que ça fait au moins
10 ans et je savais même pas que tu
serais sur le plateau oui ma chérie et
il manque un rideau
on se faisait une fontaine batailles
[Applaudissements]
cette personne est absolument adorable
pas j'ai des yeux je sais lire dans les
yeux d'amour
après c'est est-ce que tu savais
l'existence du coup de cet enfant cassé
voilà
que je connais non effectivement
c'est important de le dire aussi il nous
a coûté il y a deux ans maintenant donc
il est père de quatre enfants Samantha
Lola Jules et Oscar et Lola votre père
nous a quitté il y a deux ans et cette
toute dernière interview était
d'ailleurs chez Jordan et tout d'un coup
il parle de vous mais on sent quand même
qu'il est il est assez pudique regardez
quel rapport avec eux très bon et donc
ils savent qu'ils ont papa fantoche
fantoche et fantasque et fantasque
le fait de les avoir fait vous avez pas
aimé ce que je vais vous dire
un petit peu tard est-ce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui vous embête ou pas du
tout ivrini pas du tout pas du tout le
fait de se dire que
d'autres c'est possible c'est des choses
dont vous parlez ensemble ou pas du tout
non pardon pendant le magnéto j'ai
demandé si c'était dur de parce que je
ne sais même pas demandé c'était dur de
revoir les images parce que sinon ça me
fait très plaisir d'accord
ça peut c'est bête
et dans une interview pour Paris Match
ce qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps
vous dites que quelques mois avant de
nous quitter et vous avez fait cette
confidence cette hallucinant j'aimerais
faire entrer Christophe fille dans ma
vie mais je ne sais pas comment
c'est qui christophie
Christophe fils et ma soeur parce que
vous avez dit demi mais moi je vous
avoue c'est pas c'est pas un terme qui
faut que les gens comprennent
chez nous c'est pas un terme
avec la maman de Christophe fille qui
s'appelle la génétique non mais j'ai le
pardon mais d'un adultère
non non pas du tout mon père était à
l'époque il était absolument pas marié
avec Karine qui est qui est sa femme
depuis
il avait une histoire avec la mère de
Christophe et quand il a rencontré ma
mère
Caroline elle s'appelle Caroline était
déjà enceinte de Christophe et donc ma
mère était déjà au courant de de tout ça
il y avait quatre enfants il meurt vous
avez 34 ans et il vous dit vous avez une
sœur non ça c'est pas passé comme ça moi
je suis au courant que j'ai une sœur
depuis toujours parce que ma mère ne me
l'a jamais caché et mon père m'en a
parlé je devais avoir 16 ans c'était
pour mon anniversaire on était allé
dîner tous les deux et il m'a dit voilà
tu as une sœur qui s'appelle Christophe
qui a le même âge que toi
je vous avoue que ma mémoire s'est
arrêtée à à ça et j'ai dit est-ce que tu
peux me donner son numéro de téléphone
j'ai vraiment besoin de de la rencontrer
de lui parler à l'époque on vous
rappelle qu'on vit pas dans ce monde sur
connecté et sur informer il y a pas
Instagram il y a pas Facebook à l'époque
il y a peut-être msn je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez ou les skyblog les trucs
comme ça
bon bref et il me dit je te donnerai le
numéro de Christophe fille en temps et
en heure
trois ans plus tard quand mon père me
donne son numéro et là vous allez me
dire ce que vous allez lui dire parce
que c'est fascinant on rappelle votre
père à quatre enfants et globalement et
voilà le jour de sa mort il vous annonce
même si vous le saviez par votre mère
mais vous annonce que viennent cinquième
enfant qui est votre demi-soeur à peu
près pas le jour de sa mort parce que
c'était pas trop prévu qui meurt
est compliquée
et vous dites donc vous avez vu son
numéro de téléphone vous l'avez appelé
j'ai 16 ans quand j'ai 16 ans quand il
me le dit et j'ai 19 ans quand il me
donne le numéro de ma sœur je l'ai
appelé et on s'est rencontré donc on
s'est rencontré on avait 19 ans en effet
et qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
tant de choses on a pleuré on arrive et
on avait très très envie de se
rencontrer donc une semaine plus tard
elle est venue me voir à Paris parce
qu'elle est pas du tout parisienne et on
sentait moins seul toutes les deux elle
a vu son pardon elle a vu son père
pendant comme toi tu voyais ton père
elle a vu son père pendant elle a jamais
vu son père le soir
et aucun jugement sur votre papa c'est
pourquoi cet enfant qui qu'il a j'allais
dire j'ai envie de vous dire que il y a
des réponses que j'aurais pas parce que
par exemple ça c'est pas une question
que j'ai posé à mon père je lui ai
jamais dit pourquoi elle tu la reconnu
et pourquoi elle tu l'as pas reconnu et
pourquoi moi tu m'as reconnu
c'est pas des années de psy de se dire
que son
son père n'a pas voulu de son existence
quasiment comme je pense
c'est douloureux et ça fait mal et
d'ailleurs n'importe pour n'importe quel
enfant peu importe que votre père soit
quelqu'un de de public ou qui ça c'est
bien sûr que c'est douloureux mais après
ça se répare et c'est bien pour ça que
j'ai écrit un roman alors j'ai une
question importante parce que c'est un
roman donc on comprend que dans le roman
c'est une histoire c'est romancer mais
évidemment on comprend que c'est
l'histoire
pour les gens ils veulent c'est le
Commissaire Moulin il est populaire
c'est un grand réalisateur c'est
quelqu'un qu'on adore tous c'est moi
aussi d'ailleurs c'est pas un bouquin
qui ne met beaucoup beaucoup en avant
puisqu'on comprend finalement ce papa a
laissé tomber une fille mais c'est
surtout en fait parce que Mathieu c'est
pas du tout un bouquin sur Yves Rénier
pour commercialiser
et et je vais même te dire quelque chose
on est en train de se dire que cette
fille de la part connu il l'a pas fait
rentrer dans la famille on en parle
parce qu'en fait moi j'avais à coeur de
réparer quelque chose auprès de ma sœur
on perd de toute façon ne pourra plus
réparer vu que
il m'a pas dit Lola s'il te plaît répare
quelque chose c'était quand même
franchement pas son genre donc ce serait
mentir de dire ça par contre plusieurs
mois avant sa mort il m'avait dit un
jour dans son jardin il m'a dit tu sais
j'aimerais bien faire rentrer Christophe
fille dans ma vie mais je sais pas
comment faire voilà
c'est là où je me perds vraiment pardon
vous à ce moment-là je suis pas je n'ai
jamais dans les situations des gens mais
à ce moment-là moi ma première question
ça aurait été pourquoi tu l'as pas fait
qu'est-ce qui me bloque qu'est-ce que
c'est pas la question mais bien sûr
qu'on se la pose mais parce qu'on a on a
tous des paradoxes on a tous des
ambiguïtés et on porte tous une histoire
et on a tous une intimité moi je suis
pas dans mais on n'est pas dans
l'intimité de ces perles
donc
il y a une partie de l'histoire qu'elle
connaît par définition moi j'ai une
partie de l'histoire que je connais mais
certainement que la vérité est à
mi-chemin entre les deux versions
ma mère est celle de Chris elles se sont
rencontrées lundi dernier lundi là
ce sont dit pardon parce que c'est c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé je vais te dire
la vérité on organiser la c'était la
soirée de lancement de mon roman
princesse autonome et moi j'étais une
table en train de signer les bouquins et
mes mères se sont retrouvées et
visiblement ça c'est très très bien
passé parce que le lendemain c'était
l'anniversaire de mon fils le 14 février
et on a fêté ça toutes ensemble chez ma
mère autour d'une table et on a
absolument pas parlé de de
la Suisse vous pensez que la suite ça
peut être une maison de campagne où il y
a les deux mamans où il y a toutes les
familles et ça peut être ça mais jamais
trop tard moi je pense que l'histoire
elle peut être belle en fait et c'est
pas parce que c'est pas parce que notre
père n'a pas reconnu Christophe
aujourd'hui cette histoire ne peut pas
devenir jolie non mais je suis juste je
répète ma question parce qu'elle me
marque je dis juste que c'est beau ce
que vous faites mais ça aurait pu être
fait tout ça entre vous et que je trouve
que ça abîme
est-ce que est-ce que tu roman moi je
l'ai lu
le temps de le lire parce que tu vois
j'ai Isabelle qui m'a glissé un mot et
ça m'a énormément touché et du coup je
vais la laisser parler
[Rires]
magnifique il est très bien écrit et il
est plein d'amour
il conduit gran mais à part ça ne pas
reconnaître ça veut pas dire rejeter et
moi Yves m'y a fait on s'entendait très
très bien dans la vie mais il y a fait
allusion une fois et je ne savais pas si
c'était une blague ou pas une blague et
de la même façon que lui il n'est pas
aller plus loin moi je n'ai pas posé de
questions parce que je ne savais pas
qu'en fait
est-ce que je pose une question est-ce
que vous vous sentez aujourd'hui du coup
pas un rôle de réparatrice mais faire
beaucoup pour elle parce que peut-être
que son papa lui a pas donné la vérité
j'ai écrit ce roman pour faire du bien
que à ma soeur oui bien sûr et je pense
que c'est légitime et qui n'aurait pas
envie de faire du bien à quelqu'un qu'on
aime mais j'ai surtout écrit ce roman
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
des cœurs abîmés des cœurs blessés par
le manque d'amour des cœur blessés par
le manque de reconnaissance de
légitimité il y en a plein dans ce monde
mais le lac j'insiste
non mais parce que j'insiste et parce
que je l'aime et que je j'adore cette
phrase dans la vie il ne faut pas il
faut donner des repères et nous des
leçons je ne donne pas de leçons mais
juste je ne comprends pas comment on
peut ne pas reconnaître par ne pas faire
rentrer ton enfant mais je m'en fous les
autres mais je m'en fous des autres
comment on peut faire ça en fait cette
histoire là moi je trouve que vous avez
dit dans Paris Match après je vous
laisse la parole nous souffrions du même
chagrin le manque de compréhension de
reconnaissance et le manque de lui
croyez-moi cela crée des liens
indéfectible voilà c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut dire c'est que Yves était
quelqu'un de très charismatique qui
prenait énormément de place mais qui
n'en donnait pas beaucoup à ses enfants
en tous les cas à ces deux filles ça
j'ai été témoin et vraiment qui n'était
pas une figure paternelle type mais
c'était un super ami pour vous et à 11
ans et vous a jamais dit qu'il avait un
autre enfant oui mais c'est moi ce que
je trouve magnifique dans dans sa
démarche et dans ce qu'elle raconte en
tout cas ce qui transpire puisque je
savais même pas que tu avais écrit un
livre
ce que ce qui transpire c'est que des
gens qui ont été privés si vous voulez
et de la reconnaissance paternelle et de
l'amour paternel ce sont chargés de au
lieu d'être chargé de demande et de
manque elles sont chargées d'amour
d'envie de donner moi je veux dire je
connais assez de je connais assez
Twitter pour te dire que je suis ravi de
vous recevoir que ça va être juste
ivraignée on l'adorait on a juste appris
qu'il y a une fille maintenant qui est
parti pour 20 ans de psycho sincèrement
j'entends ce que vous me dites mais en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est de
regarder les gens dans
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un élément qui
fait qu'on les aime plus ou alors notre
amour vaut quoi qu'est-ce que vaut
l'amour comporte aux gens parce qu'on
découvre quelque chose alors on n'aime
plus les gens mais on les aime pourquoi
vous avez parlé à l'ancien Mathieu 2022
qui était un peu binaire la vie c'est
des nuances non mais c'est vrai la vie
c'est des nuances et vous avez raison
en tout cas ce que je peux vous
souhaiter c'est que dans 256
je connais pas vos frères et sœurs mais
ce qu'il a réussi en tous les casser une
carrière et une fille magnifique je peux
vous le dire et ça sera pas coupé au
montage avec mon risque rien le bouquin
c'est le l'Asie princesse autonome et
folélier et il y a une autre promo je
crois également exactement parce que je
suis au théâtre à partir du lundi 27
février dans Barbe bleue qui est
l'adaptation d'un roman d'Amélie Nothomb
du Père
[Applaudissements]